embodying richard williams because
people don't really understand what he
was truly up against absolutely yeah you
know it is um he predicted it two years
before they were born right you know he
is savant level parenting you know he
had to
learn
tennis himself he and oricine learned
how to play tennis then they learned how
to teach it to their kids it's one of
the most amazing stories you know and he
did it all
without pushing and forcing his children
he did it through god through family
through love through dedication and
devotion to one another and he did it
without tennis being their first
priority which is magnificent you're not
gonna just be representing you you will
be representing every little black girl
on earth
i'm not gonna let you down how could you
in listening to your book and then
listen to this story there's so many
parallels where people told you know so
many times where it where you were flat
on your back sometimes yeah for sure you
know and it's
one of the the
the beautiful aspects of this story is
that concept like uh
if you're if you're not dead
you still have a shot
right and that's the thing that that you
know richard and orcine and the williams
family always knew they had such
devout faith in god first and foremost
but then in
the
their love and in their uh destiny you
know and
no fear no doubt no matter what they
faced they faced it as a family and they
kept pushing it it's magnificent
what in the hell were you doing sitting
on top of that building i just want to
know because you you look great now
you've lost the weight the pictures were
scary at first when nobody knew what the
hell was going on
i was like what happened yeah no we
we we said we wanted to climb to the top
of the burj khalifa and they said you
know floor 160 and then i realized floor
160 wasn't actually the top of the burj
khalifa and then you know we we you know
we we we talked to some we have some
friends in dubai and they let us we go
all the way to the top of the burj
khalifa it's
terrifying okay that's what i want to
say you were scared
i was terrified it's like you know three
feet around and you're standing that's
the highest place on earth that you can
be in a man-made structure wow yes real
quick last thing
you got everybody paid how important was
that to get folks bonuses for you to
speak up about the pay equity yeah you
know
all i can do is my part you know so it's
always an honor and a pleasure for me to
to do my part and you know everybody put
in brilliant work it was the covet
so you know felt like you know people
really stuck with us and all of that and
and then it was you know a much more
difficult process than anybody thought
they were signing up for you know so i
just felt that it was it was fair